probably yesterday you had the the dream
Catalan in the last game against Ray
Robson you tried to emulate that in
today's game as well explained to us
this idea of Bishop 2 B3 what were you
aiming at
I actually am wondering what you mean
how how is this trying to emulate the
catalog yes The Bishop's on Beats
no I had a small idea in this game
um
I was still a bit surprised that Wesley
went for the qga but not super surprised
he does play it from time to time
and I had this very small idea which was
a based on a game grishu kremnik from
Kansas both Wesley and I played in 2018.
it was played near the end of the
tournament and so after Knight D4
kramnik played
after B5 E4 cd494 kramnik played Bishop
B7 E5 Knight E4
and it's take take Castle is extremely
unpleasant position so
so it can easily get very dangerous for
for black here yeah and Wesley played a
move which I
didn't wasn't familiar with I mean I
I thought my bd7 is supposed to be the
best move
uh and but certainly Bishop D6 is not a
bad move it's just uh I wasn't sure
exactly what to do I thought
Queen E2 here is very interesting for
example
yeah Bishop P5 Knight of I mean it turns
into a mess yeah it's very concrete it
could be very dangerous for black so
maybe I should have done this and then
Castle I really thought he would Castle
because I I thought that Bishop B7 would
allow Bishop takes E6 yes which it does
right yeah it does but then when I
started to calculate it take take Queen
E7
take take Queen D6 and like well Knights
I mean many moves Queen E7 is a move
going for that and game immediately for
example
um
or Rook G8 yeah Rook G8 I don't know if
I have like Queen E6 I think this was
some sort of a game played between Chaka
and Andrew Hong 2021 yeah Queen 266
better
queen of five Knight D7 Bishop G5 yep
uh was this the game oh I don't think so
no yeah at some point but I think Queen
E6 was still the game no G3 yeah G3 but
g39 C6 looked very
I didn't want to play G3 because now
F3 F3 is a weakness yeah and
uh of course it's also super complex I
mean probably I should have gone for
this but I I really
um
didn't think that I would be better and
I was kind of attracted to this 95 idea
and then I realized that it's uh yeah
empty idea
like okay P if he gets very greedy and
takes on D4
Queen D4 ed585 King f8 doesn't Bishop
before and I'll have a lot of fun here
of course I I didn't didn't expect he
would do this but um
but I thought after 97 I kind of made a
very strange
an either hallucination I thought like
Bishop F4 would be strong
and then I
I don't know why I thought like he
should take something but he just
castles in there and it's very stupid
for what
um because now finally the Knight is
under yeah yeah to be honest I was
getting a bit confused with all the
pieces hanging and then I realized 97
I'm probably slightly worse
uh I went for this bishop F4 which was
like an attempt just to try to end the
game but I was very worried about Knight
fd7 Knight C3 Queen F6 and it does seem
like the computer agrees with you
it's not easy three equal lights with
white yeah I I was
rather pleasantly surprised when he
decided to simplify the position
yeah because here I thought I'm not
really like
yeah D4 works even I didn't think I
would ever be worse yeah of course also
impossible for it to be better here
um but yeah it really came down to
probably finding something after Bishop
T6 and or maybe going for this bishop
takes C6 and accepting a complete mess
but uh what I did was was definitely not
good
what do you expect from your opponent
tomorrow and what are you going to bring
to the table without revealing too much
of course well I expect him to try to
press with white that's the
I mean he he's a rather solid player so
he can press in a way which doesn't take
extreme risks
that's sort of Wesley Style
um but I do have to be ready for both
possibilities that we go to a playoff or
that uh that we have a tough fight in
the classical game guys any questions a
quick one for you uh uh Fabi is uh for
us as we started our show and your
head-to-head matches with Wesley in
classical chess are you aware what your
score is
I assume it's tied it is it is it's not
I I wasn't sure exactly but it's not a
big surprise four to four with 26 draws
there's very little between you too yeah
yeah we have a very close score also I
think we've played a number of matches
and uh they've been very close matches
as well so we played like a bunch of
rabbit matches in 2020 the clutch chess
you're probably right
quite well
um and also those matches were tied one
to one so so
um we do have
a pretty tight record that's true and
yet at the same time when I think about
you both I think that you have very
different styles from one another but
somehow you match up incredibly closely
no I I agree that we definitely have
rather serious stylistic differences
but you know we we do also tend like
we're both quite good at calculation I
think that's that's the strength of
Wesley's for sure and probably also for
myself and usually if two players are
calculating
um rather than following intuition then
they tend to reach very similar
conclusions in the game so our stylistic
differences might be in terms of let's
say opening choice or
um in terms of some sort of decision
whether to you know play safely or go
for risks but in terms of our actual
chest it's probably pretty closely
matched so very good luck for you
tomorrow
there you go
um